dans une vidéo récente sur son étonnante
david thibeault se sont demandés si une
simulation des neurones humains par 100
millions d'êtres humains qui s'échangent
des signaux en corée du sud pouvait
faire émerger une conscience alors le
problème de la conscience c'est
compliqué notamment parce que ça éveille
l'hooliganisme en nous du coup on va
aborder une question plus simple est ce
que ça peut faire émerger une
intelligence une collection de
composants idiot peut-être donné lieu à
une structure macroscopique intelligente
et la réponse est oui
et pour s'en convaincre il suffit de
regarder du côté des fourmilières à
thomas j'ai envie de parler d' al
khwarizmi avant six à doivent tirer sa
part le plus tard ça marche
au 16ème siècle l'italie était le centre
du monde mathématiques avec ces génies
comme galilée torricelli ou encore
tartaglia est le summum de
l'intelligence fut alors la résolution
d'équations il y avait même des duels
public qui opposait des mathématiciens
ou donnés alors à chaque mathématicien
une liste d'équations du troisième degré
à résoudre c'est à dire des équations
comme x au cube - 9 x car et plus 17 x
égale 21
le vainqueur de tels duels étaient
considérés plus intelligent résoudre des
équations était un signe d'intelligence
au plus aujourd'hui et on peut se
demander pourquoi est ce parce que les
machines savent résoudre ce problème que
nous considérons désormais que ce
problème n'est pas une question
d'intelligence
non la résolution d'équations du
troisième degré est devenu un problème
facile c'est grâce au génie d'alcoolisme
et de ses successeurs
alcoa et demi est un mathématicien perse
du 9ème siècle après jésus-christ est
certainement l'un des personnages les
plus influents de l'histoire de
l'humanité avec khwarizmi c'est un peu
le turing du moyen âge en particulier
autour de 825 al khwarizmi publia son
oeuvre abrégée de calcul par la
restauration et la comparaison
li clarifier de nombreux outils
mathématiques aujourd'hui devenus
indispensables comme l'écriture dénombre
via la notation hindous arabe et
l'utilisation de notation abrégée qui
est au coeur de ce qui deviendra ensuite
l'algèbre alors oui je sais tout ça il
ne l'a pas inventé mais j'ai envie de
dire ce coup les inventeurs bon comme
l'écrivît le grand mathématicien william
thurston la mesure d'autres succès est
si nous permettons aux gens de
comprendre et penser plus clairement et
efficacement les mathématiques
et à ce jeu-là al khwarizmi peut être
considéré comme l'un des plus grands
mathématiciens de l'histoire aux côtés
de clips et de tueries d'ailleurs le
plus grand génie d'algorithmique y ait
vraiment sa patte personnelle fut sa
volonté d'expliquer et d'enseigner les
méthodes de résolution plutôt que les
solutions elles mêmes
si plutôt que de résoudre une équation
comme x carré - x égal 2 al khwarizmi
voulu détailler toutes les étapes de
calcul qu'il suffit de faire pour
résoudre ce genre d'équations et il
fallait que chaque étape de ce
raisonnement soit suffisamment simples
et élémentaires pour qu'il ne s'agisse
plus que d'un jeu de symbole un jeu
purement syntaxique de sorte que même le
dernier des abrutis puisse résoudre ce
genre de problème en ne faisant que
suivre les instructions
tel qu au rythme et quand je pense au
dernier des abrutis
je pense bien sûr aux machines ou à
thibault et david qui s'envoient des
messages en corée du sud depuis al
khwarizmi des générations de
mathématiciens n'ont cessé de réduire
des problèmes que seuls des
mathématiciens de grands génies savez
résoudre un simple jeu de symboles
gouverné par des instructions préétabli
cette façon de penser est sans doute
l'une des plus grandes avancées de
l'histoire des idées on l'appelle penser
highco harry smic ou de façon francisé
pensée algorithmique
cette approche consiste à combiner des
composants élémentaires idiot et à leur
faire faire des tâches bête et méchante
avec l'espoir qu'une grande multitude de
simplicité parviennent néanmoins à
résoudre des problèmes qui semblait
nécessité une intelligence fulgurante
l'intelligence fulgurante aura alors
émergé d'opérations élémentaire
simpliste alors dit comme ça ça peut
paraître être de la magie noire ou
nécessiter l'intervention géniale d'un
concepteur intelligent mais ce genre
d'émergence de l'intelligence est en
fait on ne peut plus banal dans la
nature
n'est ce pas thomas oui tout à fait les
règles simples dictant le comportement
de chaque individu sont très présentes
chez les insectes sociaux et permettent
l'émergence du comportement intelligent
de la colonie par exemple les termites
décide de prendre ou déposer un morceau
de terre en fonction des structures
autour d'eux initié par d'autres
termites
il s'agit de boucles comportementale de
renforcement si un termite réalise par
hasard une action comme déposée de la
terre un autre observera les effets de
cette action et sera plus enclin à faire
de même ce qui aura un effet de
motivation encore plus gros pour les
termites suivant le processus aboutit à
différentes formes et d'accumulation et
à la création de structures darche deux
piliers ou de tunnels
mais bien sûr vous aurez également pensé
aux fourmis qui laisse dans
l'environnement des substances chimiques
les phéromones ayant
une signification pour les fourmis
suivante comme dans le cas des termites
la communication est ici indirects
l'environnement joue le rôle de mémoire
collective et cette propriété permet à
des comportements intelligents d'émerger
en effet l'utilisation de
l'environnement comme mémoire présente
plusieurs avantages d'abord cette
mémoire est quasiment illimitées plus
des espaces plus de fourmies et la
mémoire de la colonie grandit sans
effort ensuite cette mémoire est
intimement lié à l'espace à
l'environnement chaque élément mémoriser
rattacher une position ce qui donne tout
son sens il s'agit d'une cartographie de
l'espace de l'environnement directement
rattaché à celui ci enfin cette mémoire
est sensible modifications de
l'environnement
si par exemple une colonie de fourmis
découvre des restes sur une table de
pique nique celle-ci déposeront sur le
trajet les substances indiquant le bon
repas une petite modification de
l'environnement comme un déplacement de
la table de quelques centimètres et très
peu de travail sera nécessaire pour
réparer les indications les informations
liées à la table de son pied jusqu'à la
nourriture auront encore tout leur sens
al'inverse une zone de l'environnement
trop changeantes trop chaotique aura
bien du mal à être sélectionné comme
piste durable cette gestion de la
mémoire au sein même de l'environnement
contient en elle ce qu'il faut pour
éviter une certaine forme de danger mais
rien de tel qu'une belle animation pour
illustrer tout ça et rappeler les règles
simples qui régissent le comportement
des fourmis et aboutisse à leur
intelligence de groupe
voici donc notre petite animation vous
trouverez les liens concernant le
programme dans la description
on y voit notre colonie de fourmis la
première question qu'on peut se poser
c'est comment une fourmi données peut
retrouver le chemin vers le nid situé au
centre de l'image pour ce faire il
utilise un premier type de phéromones
une substance qu'elle laisse partout sur
son trajet depuis le nil lorsqu elle le
quitte
voici à quoi ressemble notre monde si on
révèle cette trace
cette substance s'évapore au fil du
temps ce qui permet à notre fourmis de
différencier les marques plus ancienne
que d'autres elle utilisera ces
informations pour retrouver son chemin
lorsqu une fourmi découvre par hasard
une source de nourriture
celle ci en prendra un petit bout et
reviendra au nid en laissant sur son
chemin un second type de phéromones
représenté ici en rouge
prenez bien le temps d'apprécier la
simplicité dans le comportement d'une
seule fourmis les règles qu'elle suit
tiennent en quelques lignes
elle se base sur le fait qu'elles
portent déjà ou de la nourriture sur les
deux types de phéromones et son job
consiste uniquement à se déplacer soit
aléatoirement soit en suivant les traces
et à déposer elle même une des deux
substances avec seulement ces règles
pour chacune des fourmis on voit émerger
un comportement complexe et intelligente
de la colonie qui est bien davantage que
la somme des comportements de chaque
fourni prises individuellement on peut
noter l'utilisation efficace du hasard
qui est l'une des règles les plus
simples au niveau d'un seul individu un
déplacement aléatoire n'a pas grand
intérêt
mais au niveau d'un essaim il s'agit
d'une stratégie efficace de diffusion
pour explorer un maximum d espace en
dehors du rôle de cartographie des
phéromones comme par exemple indiquer le
chemin menant une source de nourriture
le mécanisme peut aussi très facilement
sélectionner les chemins les plus courts
en effet si plusieurs chemins menant à
une même source sont découverts le plus
court d'entre eux sera pris à une
fréquence plus élevée et sera donc
davantage renforcée puis privilégier les
renforcements de comportement comme ceux
initiés par les phéromones permettent
une allocation très dynamique des
ressources
on a pu constater que lorsque la
majorité des fourmis ne vois pas de
substances en rapport avec la nourriture
alors leur comportement est aléatoire et
l'intégralité de l'essaim se trouvent
nombre dans un mode de diffusion qu'on
peut interpréter comme de la recherche
sur nantes rennes voit quelque chose et
lundi qu une autre va le voir et faire
de même
puis une autre il y a une réaction
globale de la colonie où l'intégralité
des fourmis par un comportement de
collecte une fois la tâche terminée la
trace s'évapore et tout ce petit monde
reprendra son comportement d'exploration
ses boucles de renforcement permettent
des changements de comportements globaux
exponentielle et on les voit également
lors des réactions de défense où la
majorité des forces sera ainsi consacrée
à neutraliser un envahisseur
un des points fascinant liée à
l'émergence de l'intelligence via ses
mécanismes et l' équilibre entre
l'exploration c'est à dire décidé de ne
pas re fois pas écouter les féroé
et l'exploitation c'est à dire suivre à
la lettre leurs recommandations pour un
individu isolé une erreur volontaire ou
non peut être une catastrophe
une fois on n'y peut se perdre et ne
jamais retrouver le chemin vers la
colonie mais ces erreurs individuelles
sont un atout majeur dans l'intelligence
émergentes
sans elle une colonie serait incapable
de découvrir de nouvelles choses ni
d'améliorer une piste et c'est une belle
morale dans cette histoire non seulement
l'intelligence peut émerger de règles
simples mais en plus cette intelligence
pourrait disparaître si les règles
étaient plus aboutie une colonie de
fournoux parfaite qui suivra à la lettre
les recommandations des phéromones
serait bien moins performante qu'une
colonie classique deux fois j'espère que
vous ne regarderez plus les colonies de
fourmis de la même manière une fourmi
seul c'est pas super malin mais une
colonie de fourmis ça résout des
problèmes si complexe que des
informaticiens se sont inspirés pour
concevoir des intelligences
artificielles et je vais insister une
dernière fois sur l'importance de la
pensée algorithmique parce que je pense
que c'est vraiment quelque chose de très
important
on a tendance à penser que certaines
idées requiert un génie pur quelque
chose qui transcende les lois de la
physique que ce soit dans le domaine de
la composition musicale du diagnostic
médical de la négociation commerciale ou
des grandes avancées mathématiques mais
en fait la pensée à hugo rythmique n'a
cessé de décomposer les actes de génie
en une succession de raisonnement
élémentaires pour montrer que ce que
l'on croyait être intelligent s'obtient
également via une succession d'un grand
nombre d'opérations simpliste nous
encore l'histoire de l'algorithmique n'a
cessé de montrer que la formalisation de
ces étapes de calcul conduit
généralement à des optimisations du
processus de réflexion voire à des
avancées scientifiques majeures comme la
fois où turing a découvert
l'universalité de certaines de ses
machines
néanmoins même avec tous en tête il
reste difficile de se convaincre que
l'expérience de pensée de david et
thibault ces 100 milliards d'humains en
corée du sud
suffisent vraiment à l'émergence d'une
intelligence le génie de cette
expérience de pensée c'est de ramener à
notre échelle des opérations
élémentaires qui ont habituellement lieu
à des échelles beaucoup plus petit
et du coup on a tendance à s'attarder
sur chaque communication entre pairs
d'humains mais on l'a vu pour que
l'intelligence immerge il faut grande
multitude d'opérations alimenté
simpliste ne trouverait donc pas
l'intelligence dans une poignée
interactions entre humains
l'intelligence n'apparaît que lorsque
l'on considère le système entier et
toutes les opérations élémentaires dans
leur ensemble en particulier pour
observer l'émergence de l'intelligence
les 100 milliards d'humains il faudrait
observer de haut dans le ciel sur des
échelles de temps beaucoup plus long et
même là parce que le nombre de
communications à suivre du regard
dépasse de loin ce que le cerveau humain
est capable de suivre
il y a peu de chances que l'on comprenne
comment l'intelligence parvient à
émerger et will capacités cognitives du
cerveau humain sont malheureusement
limité ce n'est alors pas étonnant que
l'on préfère ignorer la complexité du
système et considérer le tout comme une
espèce de boîte noire
au final c'est un peu ça que l'on fait
lorsque l'on constate la complexité
d'une fourmilière d'une termitière
et c'est carrément ce que l'on fait
lorsque l'on constate l'émergence de
l'intelligence dans un cerveau humain et
ce n'est absolument pas une coïncidence
si c'est aussi ce que l'on fait de plus
en plus lorsque l'on constate
l'émergence de l'intelligence
artificielle de certains programmes
informatiques
j'espère que vous avez aimé cet épisode
un grand merci à thomas de la chaîne
patient seul pour son intervention la
chaîne patience que je la recommande
très vivement j'espère me délire en fin
de vidéo perdre et vidéo de thomas parce
que c'est de l'excellent de
vulgarisation qui fait d'eux des
mathématiques à l'informatique en
passant par un physique ou encore
notamment les excellentes vidéo de
thomas autour de l'informatique
notamment celle sur le terrain de la
complétude de encore c'est sur la
machine de turing notamment dedans il
explique un peu comment fonctionne une
machine de turing universelle la lymphe
on a parlé des machine de turing et
n'attend rien d'eux demande aussi du
coup de machines turing pouvait simuler
plusieurs êtres humains si on en croit
la testerine la réponse est oui
et j'aimerais aussi a ajouté que même si
l'on ne croit pas en la thèse de tortue
turing ça n'empêche pas de dire qu'un
être humain et très probablement
approximativement simule abl par une
machine à turing en tout cas
suffisamment simula bhl pour qu'elle
devienne indiscernables
en tout cas sur la simulation d'êtres
humains benoît pierre domaine
on conseille la vidéo de dirt cheap et
jean oui par l'enterrement des enfers
numérique et tout ça est pas ma lié à
plusieurs épisodes de black mirror que
je vous conseille aussi vous avez été
nombreux à questionner le statut
physique que je donne à la thèse de
church turing et j'ai l'impression qu'il
ya un petit peu d'injustice dans la
manière de traiter la tête de turc du
rail notamment par opposition à
certaines lois comme la première loi de
la thermodynamique et a souvent droit
d'interpeller nomique qui disent que
l'énergie est conservée jusqu'à
localement et que l'entropie augmente
nécessairement je suspecte notamment le
fait que parce que la thèse jury n'a été
introduite par des informaticiens
elle n'a pas le même statut physique que
si elles avaient été introduites par des
physiciens
mais en fait si on prend ces trois lois
la thèse de torture et de la première
loi de la thermodynamique à séoul lois
de la thermodynamique
on peut les traiter selon le même angle
épistémologique en particulier pour les
fans de poppers et trois lois sont
parfaitement réfutable non seulement un
saut réfutable en plus de cela la
réfutation de n'importe laquelle de ces
lois a des conséquences sociétales
majeures
c'est être capable de concevoir une
machine qui produit de l'énergie à
partir de rien ou qui est capable de
réduire l'entropie d'un système physique
des applications sont énormes puisque en
gros vous seriez en train de résoudre le
problème de l'énergie et du
réchauffement climatique et tout ça de
la même manière si vous êtes capable de
concevoir une machine qui effective des
calculs qu'aucune machine de turing est
capable de faire ce serait une
révolution dans le monde de
l'informatique des technologies il ya
des milliards voire des millions de
milliards de dollars en jeu que je veux
dire par là c'est que c'est pas juste
des postulats qui voit la soupe est
voisin de fausses ou trompeuses dans pas
du tout si jamais une de ces lois est
posée si vous arrivez à prouver qu'elle
est fausse avec une construction de
machines
qui fait qu'ils violent l'une de ces
trois lois vous résolvez un problème
majeur de la société et vous devenez
immédiatement multimilliardaire
incentives pour montrer que ces lois
sont fausses sont énormes
est ce le fait que ces initiatives sont
si énormes et que personne n'a réussi à
construire de telles machines qui me
conduit à considérer que ces trois lois
sont très très très très crédible
beaucoup plus crédible que la relativité
générale où ça va trop bas parce que si
vous violez une certaines lois de la
mécanique quantique demain je suis pas
sûr qu'elle aura une conséquence
sociétal quelconque
alors romain lepage entier sur le fait
que lui selon lui et elles seront mieux
adaptés aux médias milk est plus
crédible que la thèse de chars sur i
j'aurais tendance à plus ou moins le
rejoindre en fait même un petit peu
matinée dans la vidéo précédente
je pense que j'ai finalement peut-être
plus confiance au final la souris doit
déterminer un ennemi qu'est crainte et
de tueurs futuring mais voilà seniors un
numéro depuis le reste est beaucoup
moins crédible à mes yeux d'ailleurs une
citation d'einstein qui disait un peu ça
que l'élysée cambo elle seconde loi
datée emmener michael restera vrai bien
des années bien des siècles après que la
relativité générale aura été rejetée
comme le fait remarquer en main le bal
dans les deux cas il s'agit d'une
question d'information et je pense que
c'est vraiment quelque chose de
fondamental en fait je pense que la
notion est plus fondamentales de
l'univers c'est pas l'énergie c'est pas
à la vitesse c'est pas la position c pas
l'espace et dans le temps
peut-être que le concept le plus
fondamental c'est peut-être plus tôt
l'information qu'il corollaire de tout
ça c'est que si on a plus fondamental
étudie l'univers
c'est via l'étude des machines nature et
paule amblard eux demandent aussi le
fait que le temps soit continue n'est
pas une contradiction avec la machine de
turing donc a priori si je crois
vraiment la tête au show arthur ashe et
du tout en sapant c'est que le temps est
discret mais la thèse de sortir elle
n'est pas nécessairement incompatibles
avec le temps continue est question
c'est est ce que dans un monde le temps
et continue on arrivera à construire des
machines qui sont capables de faire
faire et si on tient compte du fait que
l'énergie d'un système est souvent fini
tu as très classique en physique on se
rend compte que ça pose des limites sur
ce qui peut être communiquée bien
particulière 1948 des plus grands
mathématiciens du xxème siècle claude
shannon publiés peut-être l'article le
plus influent du xxème siècle puisque
c'est celui qui nous a amenés à
raisonner en termes digital plutôt qu'en
termes analogique avant ce papier en eau
des gens se disaient mais peut-être que
mj tu peux faire aussi bien que le
digital est en fait le truc c'est que
même si le temps et continue pour
envoyer beaucoup d'informations par
seconde
il faut utiliser une fréquence d'un
signe du signal qui est très très très
grande sauf que planck et einstein avait
déjà montré que de grande fréquence
était associé à beaucoup d'énergie donc
si les ingés est fini il y avait une
quantité finie aussi d'informations on
peut envoyer par seconde en tout cas à
travers un canal de communication
en fait ce que montre et chalonnes c'est
que tout canal de communication a une
capacité de communication qui est borné
qui limite à 3 pour pouvoir effectuer un
calcul
même à l'intérieur d'un microprocesseur
il est indispensable de communiquer des
informations
et si les capacités de communication
sont limitées alors la vitesse de
quelques spécialités non pas parce que
le temps est discret mais parce que
l'énergie n'atteint va interne nous
demandent aussi la pièce de george
shearing un pic le fait que l'univers et
déterministe 1 sont proscrits possède so
we de saulty gagner nous demande du coup
si la machine de turing est capable de
simuler le hasard or dare cette question
je suspecte le fait qu' il ya le
raisonnement ce préquel l'amérique tic
serait quelque chose de fondamentalement
aléatoire ça c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'interprétation de copenhague de mes
clips quantique et c'est une
interprétation de l'obliqué de l'antique
mais ce n'est pas la seule et en fait il
ya pas mal de physiciens qui préfèrent
d'autres interprétations de mes clients
tic notamment certaines d'autres
interprétations de la mécanique
quantique sont purement déterministe
comme par exemple la théorie des
multivers quantique d'everett ou encore
la théorie baume yonne et là vous
renvoie vers l'excellente vidéo de
looking glass universe à ce sujet bref
tout ça pour dire que j'ai bien moins
confiance en fait le fait qu'il existe
du hasard dans l'univers quand la thèse
de church tuerie car ceci dit la
question reste très intéressante comment
est-ce que machine naturelle peut
générer du hasard il ya deux façons de
faire la première c'est simplement de
supposer qu'elle
ac c'est un générateur de nombres
aléatoires donc on peut imaginer que
l'univers est simulée par une machine
naturelle qui de temps en temps tu iras
nombres aléatoires et l'utilisent dans
son calcul
mais on n'est peut-être pas obligé d'en
arriver jusque là si on veut tout
simplement avoir quelque chose qui
allait khaled toi on peut se contenter
des nombres pseudo aléatoires nombre de
pseudo aléatoires
c'est un truc et qui en pratique et
indiscernables d'un truc aléatoire vous
renvoie vêtements vers une vidéo que
j'ai fait sur zeta bike avec bva
blanchard m'avait parlé de la définition
de martin 9 de ce qu'hier en tout cas
l'histoire et selon martin hoff un truc
ne peut être aléatoire que s'il est
infinie déjà c'est un peu compliqué ces
univers un nombre fini d'information on
va essayer si minable originaux turing
fini ta montrerait qu'on n'est pas
capable de dire qu'elle est aléatoire en
tout cas pas au sens de martin 9 mais
surtout il ya des conjectures important
tant dans l'informatique théorique ou
attendant on se demande est ce qu'il est
possible de générer des truites qui
ressemble un truc aléatoire et on est un
moyen une conjecture qui les pose la
question de ce qui est possible de
générer un truc parfaitement
déterministe mais qui pour quelqu'un
dont la puissance de calcul est limité
et indiscernables du hasard et ce genre
de générateurs pseudo aléatoires pour
les appelle c'est un truc qui est
fondamentale en cryptographie par
exemple et c'est vraiment utiliser de
plus en plus donc en haut de façon
pratique on pense aujourd'hui on sait
répondre de l'héritage la culture mais
on pense aujourd'hui qui existe des
trucs sont largement capables de simuler
un truc qui en tout cas pour nous est
complètement indiscernable du hasard
mais au final si la mécanique quantique
bar est aléatoire c'est peut-être aussi
parce qu'il utilise ce genre de
procédure enfin exactement mega est
close car dior pose la question du
statut de l'ordinateur quantique et ça
c'est vraiment un truc
faire tellement de vidéos sur
informatique quantique a tellement de
choses à dire ta moyenne excellent livre
quantum computer inc six démocrates et
scott aronson que je recommande vivement
même si pas forcément toujours facile à
lire
l'autre cas qui est complètement fou qui
a été vraiment une surprise en scène des
années 90 c'est le fait que les
ordinateurs quantiques sont capables de
faire de calculs qu'aucune machine de
turing est capable de simuler en temps
réaliste d'un climat chine lightning
sera encore capable de simuler les
ordinateurs quantiques
mais il en faudra beaucoup plus de tes
calculs un ordinateur quantique peuvent
ne pas être isolement à ce qui se passe
sur un ordinateur classique en tout cas
un intermittent de calcul il ya
notamment un algorithme et qui s'appelle
l'alcoolisme de grover qui n'a pas
d'équivalent classics d'air que le temps
de calcul de cet algorithme est
nécessairement plus rapide et même
quadrathlon plus rapide que ce que l'on
aurait avec une machine classique
il ya vraiment un gain à utiliser des
meilleurs ordinateurs quantiques
cependant on peut se demander si ce gain
est vraiment nécessairement important
parce qu'une progression quadratique
c'est bien mais c'est pas
révolutionnaire la grande question qui
se pose c'est ce qui peut avoir des
gains vraiment significatif à passer de
l'ordinateur classique à l'ordinateur
quantique en informatique quand on dit
significatifs seront en fête
exponentielle puisqu'elle est vrai qu on
peut faire avec un ordinateur classique
pour toi raisonnable et qu'on ne peut
pas faire avec un ordinateur classique
c'est ce n'est en utilisant un temps
exponentielle aujourd'hui on pense que
la réponse est oui enfin beaucoup
d'informaticiens pense qu'en france et 8
qu'il y a quelques problèmes bien il n'y
a pas énormément et c'est une poignée de
problèmes qui sont souvent reliés à la
cryptographie moussa des conséquences
pratiques très importante mais c'est
juste une poignée de problème ton sec
l'ordinateur quantique est capable de
résoudre efficacement mais dont on pense
que le radiateur classique n'est pas
capable en tout cas on ne sait pas
encore question ouverte
en fait cette question a peut être
formalisée en la question est ce que b q
p est égal ap aujourd'hui on n'est pas
du tout la réponse à cette question
un truc qui dépasse très largement ce
qu'on sait faire maintenant
l'informatique théorique mais aura
tendance à penser que les réponses et
donc vécu paix est en fait strictement
plus gros cube et c'est à dire qu'il ya
des problèmes que les ordinateurs
quantiques sont capables de résoudre
exponentiellement plus rapidement que
des ordinateurs classiques en quel cas
la thèse de church du ring et tendu qui
dirait que tout l'univers peut être
simulé par un ordinateur classique
entend efficace de manière efficace en
temps réel bond à ce moment là cette
thèse serait fausse cependant on a alors
immédiatement une variante de la thèse
de church turing qui est plus adapté au
monde quantique qui s'appelle tout
bêtement la thèse du torch tuerie
quantique et ça aujourd'hui à bruz
d'informaticiens qui pense que la
réponse est oui la thèse de church
turing quantique est vrai c'est à dire
que tout l'univers peut être simulé par
une machine de turing quantique ou par
un ordinateur quantique pas figurer
énormément plus de choses à dire sur
tous ces sujets des trucs passionnants
sur ce qu'on appelle la théorie de
complexité malheureusement vous avez
choisi de parler dire et pas tel qu'on
rythmique du coup je vais être obligé de
laisser un peu tout ça de côté et de ne
parler que d'intelligence artificielle
elle espère que j'avais mais cette vidéo
notamment sur l'émergence de
l'intelligence dans la nature qui est
quelque chose en fait extrêmement
comment la prochaine fois on va parler
de la logique a tendance à penser que
l'intelligence est très liée à la
logique voire qu'il suffit d'être
logique pour être intelligent qu'un dans
la prochaine vidéo on va voir que cet
argument ne tient pas du tout la rue que
la logique ne suffit pas à
l'intelligence et je vais notamment
utilisé des notions d'informatique
théorique pour vous en convaincre
si vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à
la ligue et à la commenter à la partager
point de pavant quebecers épisode dans
ce département et j'espère que je serai
là
la prochaine fois nous avons 100
milliards de neurones figurez-vous
maintenant imaginez qu'on réunisse 100
milliards d'êtres humains ça peut
sembler énorme mais en fait en mettant
juste un être humain par mètre carré ça
tiendra en corée du sud et supposer
qu'on fasse agir c'est 100 milliards
d'êtres humains les uns avec les autres
de la même façon que des neurones par
exemple chacun tr min un appareil qui
permet de recevoir un signal et d'en
émettre à d'autres de la même façon que
les neurones peuvent être activés par
d'autres neurones et transmettre cette
activation à d'autres ce système formé
de 100 milliards d'êtres humains
réaliserez à une autre échelle
exactement la même fonction que mon
cerveau maintenant mais dira-t-on que ce
système a une pensée qu'il a une
véritable conscience semblable voire
identiques à ma conscience et aussi
comme il est possible de simuler un
transistor électrique avec juste
de l'eau et puis un système de vannes de
pompes et de bassines on pourrait
imaginer un système hydraulique
gigantesque qui reproduirait le
fonctionnement d'un ordinateur simulant
une conscience et du coup un énorme
ensemble de bassines et de ponte serait
conscient comme toi